Marvel fans have long adored Chris Evans
take on the iconic superhero Captain
America but now he's at the end of the
line with his movie contract what does
that actually mean for the MCU
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'll be explaining what
the events of endgame mean for the
future of Captain America the real
reason behind caps choice in the movie
and why we may get a Steve Rogers
spin-off my Marvel giveaway still
running so subscribe and leave a comment
about Captain America for a chance to
win spoilers ahead if you haven't seen
the movie yet at the end of endgame
Steve Rogers goes on one final mission
to place the Infinity stones back in
their original locations Steve returns
but not quite as expected and we
discover he's made two major decisions
that will alter the future of the MCU
first during his trip to the Past he
married his long-lost loved Peggy Carter
and then he returned as old man Steve
bringing with him a new Captain America
shield which he gave to Sam Wilson Sam
accepts the shield's signaling that he
will become the new Captain America this
decision has left some fans surprised as
they were expecting Bucky to be Steve
successor as he's been around longer
than Falcon in the MCU and the
friendship between Steve and Bucky has
been given particular prominence in the
Captain America movies I can go buy my
own I'm with you to the end of the line
pal I'm not gonna fight you
give them one of my in fact before Steve
leaves the current timeline to return
the Infinity stones he has a heartfelt
goodbye with Bucky whose words I'm gonna
miss you buddy show that he knows Steve
isn't going to come back the same man as
he left Steve also tells Bucky not to do
anything stupid until he gets back and
Bucky replies how can I you're taking
all the stupid with you which is a sweet
callback to this moment in caps first
movie when Bucky left Steve to go to war
don't do anything stupid until I get
back how can I take another stupid with
you like Sam Bucky has been Captain
America in the comics and given how the
passing of the shield from Steve to
Bucky has been foreshadowed many times
in the MCU some fans have been upset
that Steve didn't give him the shield in
the end now Bucky may still become
Captain America in the future but there
are several good reasons why now isn't
necessarily the right time for him first
of all we need to remember that Bucky
was only recently rehabilitated when he
was taken to a candor at the end of
civil war to have the Hydra programming
removed from his brain this was
successful but Bucky still had to wait
through a recovery period during which
he became the white wolf in Wakanda and
although he fought alongside the
Avengers in in thirty war Bucky may not
be ready yet for something like becoming
Captain America in fact during civil war
Bucky reveals the doubts he has about
himself to Steve I don't know if I'm
worth all this to you but you did all
those years it wasn't you we didn't have
a choice I know but I did it and there
is a problem before the events of
affinity war an endgame Bucky was a
wanted assassin and even if his crimes
have been forgiven after he stood with
the Avengers against Thanos the powers
that be for example Thunderbolt Ross
might try and stand in the way of
someone with such a troubled history
taking up the mantle of Captain America
especially given that Bucky killed Tony
Stark's parents after all it was Tony's
father Howard who created the original
Captain America shield perhaps more
importantly though there's a good chance
that Steve doesn't want to place the
weight and responsibility of being
Captain America on Bucky shoulders at
this point in time given all his friend
has been through in any case Bucky seems
at ease with how Steve left him at the
end of Avengers endgame and it's quite
possible that Bucky had a conversation
with Steve off screen before he left to
travel back in time
indeed the Russos have confirmed that
when the per say goodbye to each other
and Bucky says I'll miss you clearly
Bucky knows something
Cap'n Bucky's possible off-screen
conversation could explain why Bucky
tell Sam to go ahead and talk to Steve
after he returns from the past in fact
after Steve tell Sam to try on the
shield Sam looks back to Bucky as if to
check with him and Bucky nods back in
approval as if he already knew this
moment was coming so when Sam accepts
the shield and says he'll do his best
and Steve replies that's why it's yours
it's a subtle indication that Sam has
the right mindset to become the new
Captain America the parting of the
mantle from Steve to sam was cleverly
foreshadowed several times during
endgame when Steve is acting as a
counselor to help people work through
how they feel about the world after
Thanos is snap it parallels nicely with
Sam's work as a PTSD counselor for
veterans in the Winter Soldier film then
later as Kat was about to make his solo
last stand against Thanos Steve hears
Sam's voice through his earpiece saying
on your left as all the dusted heroes
return for that ethnic Avengers Assemble
moment Sam's on your left is a lovely
hat tip to Steve's first words to Sam in
the Winter Soldier film and again
foreshadows house Steve and Sam will
later swap roles at the close of endgame
likewise there's more to cap and Sam's
final conversation than first meets the
eye when Steve tells Sam to try on the
shield then asked him how it feels some
says like it's someone
else's Steve's reply that it isn't not
only confirms that he sees Sam as a new
captain but it's also a reminder that
this isn't Steve's original shield
because that one was broken when Thanos
smashed it during the final battle in
endgame this new shield was seemed to be
one that Steve has brought to Sam from
the alternate reality that he lived in
when he went back to live with Peggy
when Steve decided to return to the
present timeline he knew that a Captain
America shield didn't exist any longer
so it's possible that in his alternate
reality Steve asked Peggy Howard's staff
or even Toni to get him a shield for Sam
another possibility is that there was a
falcon who was Captain America in
Steve's alternate reality and now Steve
is bringing our present-day Sam that
other Falcon the shield Vulcan adopting
caps title also nods back to the comics
where it's happened a few times the most
interesting example that relates to
Avengers endgame is from 2014 when Steve
passed on the shield to Sam after he'd
lost his super soldier powers and turned
into an old man so what does Sam taking
the Captain America shield mean for
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan's new
TV show on Disney Plus well as their
series is called Falcon and Winter
Soldier it seems like Sam might need a
little while to work himself up to being
Captain America and all that title
entails likewise that would also give
fans time to adjust to a new actor
stepping into Chris Evans super shoes as
for Bucky fans they may still see the
Winter Soldier pick up the shield at
some point during the show after all
Sebastian Stan did tell fans back in
2016 at Nerdist Civil War movie marathon
that marble had told him that eventually
Bucky was going to become Captain
America another interesting possibility
that the introduction of alternate
timelines has brought the MCU is that
although Steve Rogers story and endgame
did wrap up his character arc nicely
there's still potential for future films
or TV shows about Steve and Peggy's
alternate life together
in fact the Russos have confirmed that
when Steve went back in time he created
a branched reality and they said there's
a possible story to be told about what
Steve did in that reality and how he
ended up coming back to give the shield
to Falcon I'm sure many would love to
see a Steve Rogers and Peggy Carter
movie but right now Chris Evans contract
has ended and he's doubtless looking
forward to playing a wider variety of
roles going forward he's also talked
about wanting to
the MCU on a high or to use his own
words you want to get off the train
before they push you off still it's
possible Evans might entertain coming
back at some point in the future maybe
the upcoming Disney Plus shows could be
something he'd consider for example one
of the new Marvel shows is an animated
what-if series and the very first
episode will explore what would have
happened if Peggy Carter had been given
the Super Soldier Serum in place of
Steve who instead will eventually join
World War two using a metal suit created
by Howard Stark according to reports the
what-if series will feature the voices
of actors from the MCU movies so
hopefully at the very least we'll get to
hear Hayley Atwell and Chris Evans as
the voices of Peggy and Steve in that
show as for the longer term well there's
plenty of actors who've gone back to
roles that they thought they'd left way
in their past
so Never Say Never how do you feel about
Falcon becoming Captain America and
would you like to see Chris Evans return
to the MCU comment below and be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell to enter my
mob or giveaway next tap left to check
out how Ironman actually predicted the
ending of Avengers endgame or another
video you're sure to LIKE and if you
enjoyed this a thumbs up and a share are
hugely appreciated thanks for watching
and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers